استراليا تستعد لاستبدال طائراتها من طراز
تايجر التي تنتجها شركه ايرباص بطائرات
اباتشي من فراس اي اتش 64 اي الصفقه شملت
29 طائره من طراش افاتشي وبلغت قيمتها نحو
4 مليارات ونصف المليار دولار ومن المقرر
ان تبدا في استلامها بحلول عام 2025 بهذا
تكون استراليا هي المشغل التاسع عشر
لطائرات افاتشي حول العالم حيث تتميز
مروحيات الاباتشي بانخفاض التكلفه
التشغيليه كما انها ايضا تعد خيارا اكثر
فتكا واقل خطوره على المشغل مقارنه
بطائرات تايجر هذا وكانت شركه قد اعلنت من
جانبها عن ان الصفقه ضمن عقد يشمل انتاج
184 طائره للجيش الامريكي وكذلك لدول
حليفه حيث سيحصل الجيش الامريكي على 130
طائره بينما تتقاسم مصر واستراليا الاربع
وخمسين طائره المتبقيه
اعلنت القوات الجويه الامريكيه عن تاجيل
تسيير اول رحله لاحدث قذفت قنابل في
الاسطول الجويه الامريكي
والتي تنتجها شركه نورثروب بروما التاجيل
سيكون لبضعه اشهر عن الموعد المتفق عليه
مع الشركه لكن الاخيره اكدت ان القاذفه
ستحلق خلال هذا العام من دون تحديد موعد
نهائي يذكر انه قد تم الكشف عن قاذفه
الاولى في ديسمبر من العام الماضي بعد نحو
ثلاثه عقود من العمل على تطويرها
يعتبر هذه القذفه بمثابه المكمل للثالوث
النووي الامريكي والذي يشمل صواريخ
باليسيه تطلق من الصوامع وكذلك غواصات
تطلق رؤوسا حربيا
[موسيقى]
كوريا الجنوبيه تعزز قدراتها الدفاعيه
بالمزيد من مقاتلات اف 35 الشبحيه هذه
المقاتلات التي تصنعها شركه لوكيد مارتن
الامريكيه في خطه بلغت قيمتها مليارين و
850 مليون دولار على ان يتم تسليم هذه
الطائرات بحلول عام 2028 كوريا الجنوبيه
التي لم تعلن عن عدد هذه الطائرات لديها
بالفعل موافقه من الخارجيه الامريكيه على
شراء 20 طائره اخرى بخلاف اربعين طائره
تخدم بالفعل لدى الجيش الكوري الجنوبي
[موسيقى]